carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
un gusto saludarles desde dordoña en el
suroeste de francia les doy la
bienvenida desde el castillo de mi
londres residencia que perteneció a la
bailarina cantante y resistente
josephine baker y hoy nuestro programa
lo dedicaremos a esta figura nacida en
eeuu aquí en francia homenajea con su
entrada simbólica al panteón nacional
[Música]
conoceremos la residencia de josephine
baker el castillo de milonga que fue su
ciudad mundo un oasis de paz a imagen de
las ideas humanistas de baker josephine
baker es la primera artista negra no
nacida en francia que entra al panteón
nacional francés fueron 10 años de
movilización y de una petición lanzada
por numerosas figuras políticas y de la
cultura baker conoció la segregación
racial en eeuu y la gloria en parís
revolucionó el mundo del espectáculo y
de la vida nocturna parisina y puso su
firma en la canción francesa lo veremos
en este programa
[Música]
josephine baker nació en 1906 en el seno
de una familia muy pobre de missouri y
en un contexto de segregación racial en
eeuu pero fue en francia donde se
convirtió en una estrella de los
escenarios y militantes anti racistas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la región de las artes se encuentra en
el castillo de mi londres una residencia
en el corazón de la dordoña que
josephine baker convirtió junto a su
esposo joe bullón en un templo de paz
tras la segunda guerra mundial aquí
vivieron junto a sus doce hijos
adoptivos de nacionalidades diferentes
porque como ella decía la raza humana es
sólo uno
[Música]
y en el castillo de mi lado no tenemos
cita con la actual propietaria del lugar
angelique de la bajo la amarilla
carolina o jelly que cuéntenos casi 50
años después de la muerte de josephine
baker su recuerdo sigue vivo en este
lugar sí porque mis padres compraron en
el castillo en 2001 y desde este momento
he trabajado toda mi vida para ellos y
sin baker todas las salas están
dedicadas sí a los de fin todos sus
trajes y la parte artística me parece
importante con el cinturón de bananas
por ejemplo tengo el traje de este
cinturón también lo que es más
importante para mí es la parte del área
distante una mujer que luchó durante la
segunda guerra mundial para francia para
que francia esté libre en esta época y
poco a poco el visitante puede ver
también la parte de la lucha contra el
racismo y contra las discriminaciones y
ahora en este castillo también está
justamente una sala dedicada a la
resistencia a su vida como resistente y
creo saber que en 1961 recibió en este
castillo la legión d'honneur que es la
condecoración más alta que da francia
y me parece muy extraño que tuvo esta
legión de honor únicamente en el 61 pero
la recibió frente al castillo delante
del castillo con todos los militares de
esta época y para ella pienso que era
muy orgullosa de tener esta legión de
honor también tenemos que decir que tuvo
también la cruz de guerra la cruz de la
resistencia y la cruz de la francia
libre es un honor excepcional para una
mujer que no era francesa al principio y
también que era negra y justamente ahora
que usted habla de la segregación racial
que fue algo que ella vivió en eeuu en
esta sala también podemos ver su faceta
como militante anti racista si la
militante es lo que me fascina una
persona que luchó toda su vida desde su
infancia cuando está frente a las
discriminaciones en su país y poco a
poco ella va a mostrar que se puede
vivir convivir entre muchos niños y
niñas
porque va a adoptar a doce hijos en su
castillo de los 1.011 angelique el
público viene a descubrirlas vienen
muchas personas de france y del mundo a
descubrir a josephine baker aquí si poco
a poco las personas se dan cuenta de la
importancia de los the filmmaker y de
este castillo en el que ella vivió
durante casi 30 años es mucho era su
residencia principal y ha vivido en este
lugar que tiene una emoción particular
me parece que ellos de fin nos ha dado
algo excepcional aquí y se siente mucho
su alma
gracias a angelique del abad por
recibirnos en este castillo de mil
adonde residencia de josephine baker
quien entra simbólicamente al panteón
nacional francés y esto fue posible
gracias a la movilización de muchas
figuras políticas y culturales es lo que
nos explicó yasmina el perro el
presidente del consejo departamental de
dordoña
esta historia empezó con registro que es
una personalidad francesa un hombre
político un filósofo fue el primero a
decir josephine baker
merece de entrar en el panteón luego han
organizado una petición y en algunos
meses
creo que son más de 30.000 firmas que
incidieron o pidieron que los de phil
marcar puede entrar en el panteón
soy firme que era una persona
extraordinaria
era una mujer en el panteón hay sólo
cinco mujer ahora era una persona de
color era un artista
fue una persona que entre en la
resistencia durante la segunda guerra
mundial fue una luchadora contra el
racismo en su país en los eeuu y fue una
persona que dejó a la humanidad una
experiencia única
josephine en bakker aquí en lima y
lambda creó un pueblo del mundo y al
doctor 12 niños y niñas de origen en
diferentes que era su familia y con este
acto quería mostrar que no había sitio
para el racismo en nuestro planeta y que
la gente de todas origen de todos los
países podía vivir juntos como lo
hiciera materno tranquilo ayer dream
tenemos un sueño y este sueño es un
sueño de paz es un sueño del respecto y
es un honor para la francia demostrar
que el humanismo de la paz son valores
que tenemos que mostrar al mundo
bueno
josephine baker llegó a parís en 1925 y
rápidamente se convirtió en una estrella
de los años locos una artista exótica
talentosa y atrevida que dejó su huella
en la vida nocturna parisina abrió su
propio cabaret el sello sefin en el
barrio de mónaco y es lo que vamos a
descubrir de la mano de brian scott
butler quien nos hizo la visita
[Música]
one el sprint me llamo brian scott
bailey soy coreógrafo historiador
activista y apasionado por el universo
de josephine baker
estamos en el distrito 9 de parís en el
bar carrusel que antes era un cabaret y
se llamaba el carrusel de parís y muchos
años atrás el 10 de diciembre de 1926
las maravillosas josephine baker su
agente pep y sabatino decidieron abrir
aquí su primer cabaret
y ver cómo era la energía en esa época
era como celebraron un cumpleaños
navidad y año nuevo juntos había la cena
con conciertos de jake hechas la banda
de baker para también charleston tango y
black botó ella a veces bailaba aquí
realizaba un espectáculo en full y
bergero en otro escenario como el teatro
campos elíseos donde empezó su carrera y
luego venía directo aquí para seguir
bailando
[Música]
xinyu performing
como map
en esa época uno venía amo martes para
festejar le había fiestas para todos los
gustos con revistas que promocionaban
diferentes cabarets desde clubes
libertinos hasta clubes de tango clubes
rusos o simplemente de clubes de jazz de
artistas afroamericanos inmigrantes de
eeuu que se habían instalado en parís
einstein
[Música]
josephine baker la gente que venía a
josephine era de clase alta príncipes
princesas gente de la élite periodística
como georges simenón o artistas como el
japonés fuji está la escritora colette
también frecuentaba
baker lo maravilloso de este lugar aquí
en el 40 rubial fontaine es que su
historia de felicidad y diversión siguió
por ejemplo fue aquí que se dio el
primer espectáculo de una mujer trans se
llamaba cox sin él y bailó en el
carrusel de parís
sastre también canto a que llamaban al
carrusel de parece el pequeño acabaré
más grande de parís
la energía de josephine baker también y
rigo la música y la canción francesa es
lo que nos explica ya mismo natal y
olivares
[Música]
si me quieres
recordando a hechos es tim baker frente
al poste o su residencia eterna junto a
otros grandes hombres y grandes mujeres
de la nación aquí en pleno corazón de
parís el gran amor de josephine baker
[Música]
he pasado mis huellas del colectivo
hola país ciudad luz que recibió a
josephine baker cuando tenía 19 años
aquí que creció conoció la fama se
enamoró un amor incondicional que la
llevó incluso a pelearse a luchar para
que esta ciudad sea liberada de los
alemanes durante la segunda guerra
mundial
[Música]
josephine baker le cantaba a las tropas
francesas contra los nazis e incluso
transportaba mensajes secretos de la
resistencia en sus partituras musicales
los mensajes eran codificados y escritos
con tinta transparente
[Música]
ay
su lucha fue reconocida y parís liberada
josephine baker terminó su vida aquí en
parís y su gran éxito de la canción de
desamor mup el padre se convirtió
después de la segunda guerra mundial en
mi país es parís
sí
no no no
no
gracias natalia olivares y con el tema
jet2 vamos a despedir este programa
especial carrusel de las artes que
dedicamos a josephine baker con motivo
de su entrada simbólica al partido
nacional francés muchísimas gracias por
su sintonía y hasta la próxima wow
[Música]
por esas
no
y vino